all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
Hummer today we'll be going over the
fried liver attack so in my last lecture
I went over the Italian game and then
got some flax in the comments section
here all right says a Jared plane three
minutes into the video and mike has
already made two completely incorrect
statements about that time game three
Knight f6 four black obviously allowing
for Knight g5 is perfectly sound and
playable for black well let's see if
that's really the case as my buddy right
down there he explains dude it's for
beginners I mean you don't want to go
into the fried liver attack if you're
black and then a very astute legally
Phoenix explains that sometimes if you
play h6 as I recommend as opposed to
Knight f6 you can still get sacrificed
on f7
which is true as we'll see in the fourth
game alright so here are the games so I
am playing not a kid not a 900 not even
a 100 and actual 1700 Preston Smith the
chimp in a rated game ok so here we go
do I play efore he plays a 5 I wonder
where this is going I trick him into
playing the fried liver attack it
instead are going into it instead of
playing Knight f3 I first bring out my
bishop and so he's like yeah I'll play
Knight f6 and attack your pawn and then
okay I'll attack your pawn and it's like
okay I'll defend my point and little
does he know he's in the fried liver
attack now but hey perfectly playable
for black right well let's see alright
so now I'm jumping in I'm attacking f7
here alright so so obviously d5 should
be a plate here and so take
a knight takes and whenever you get the
opportunity here to go into the fried
liver attack do it alright Knight takes
f7 King takes up seven one they might
not know the theory there might be like
what the heck I've developed both my
Knights I'd done everything just perfect
you know I'm playing all sound and all
of a sudden I'm getting destroyed here
okay and so now after the check as we'll
see in the next game black should play
his King to e6 here and that's the last
place you want your King to be obviously
but he doesn't want his King in the in
the center for the entire game and he
doesn't want to defend he wants to be on
the attack so he's like forget it you
can just have the pawn and uh and get on
with it so after so he blocks with the
Queen here actually and makes my life
very easy so Bishop takes Czech Bishop
blocks with the check and now I captured
the knight and so now he's got these
double isolated ponds and an isolate
opponent over here hello Kevin and so
now I'm up material I could be greedy
and take another pawn but I'm playing
the champ here Preston and I know he is
the best with his a queen so it's an
advantage to me because I know my
opponent and I know his tendencies even
if he gets down early because he's got
this Queen he might be able to come back
and beat me here so so if I have an
opportunity to eliminate the guys best
piece I'm going to do it so check even
though it kind of helps his uh pawn
structure out okay
so who thinks I should castle here
okay so alright so we're getting a lot
of boats forecastle alright so so if I
Castle here I'm going to be giving him a
lot of counterplay you know I don't want
to give him a lot of counterplay so I
don't get Castle instead I just try to
get some of my pieces off the back row
here so f5 bring my night out alright so
he attacks my pawn I want to move my
bishop right so I can just protect the
pond with other pawns that's who should
be protecting pawns other points alright
so obviously he's well he attacks my
other pawn so same thing I just push it
up so now he puts my knight in a pin so
Bishop d2 breaks the pin and and would
allow me to castle on my next turn
that's what I should have played instead
I'm was I will my bishop on this long
diagonal so I play Bishop to b2 but now
I'm still pinned and I totally miss his
uh his tactic here Bishop the d5 attacks
mabrook so I want to castle over here
I think that's where my king is going to
be the safest so I I don't castle so I
play Rick to g1 and now what's a really
good move for black here that prevents
my whole castling strategy Bishop f3 yes
so now I can't castle so I don't even so
I don't play King to d2 because that
would be nonsense it would keep me in a
pin so I want to break the pin so a3
Bishop back break the pin bishop here so
notice this Bishop you know when I play
Knight to a4 it's forced to be traded
but what I really want to take say for
instance he just passes what I really
want to take and straight up all those
pawns probably not
okay so but he makes it easy for me he
plays Bishop there and so I instantly
take it
he pawn takes and now I got a really
good night a night that can just stay
there forever but first things first I
don't want to if I play Knight to c5
here he can obviously give me a check I
move
give me another check get all the way
down there check and I'd be in a lot of
trouble okay so so we got to look watch
out for you know checks and captures and
all that good stuff
so King up prevents that so now
obviously if you were play here which he
doesn't I would just challenge the file
alright instead he plays a5 threatens to
take my pawn so I protect it so he takes
the fun so so I I take it and now I
don't mind trading the rooks and I'm
also threatening this pawn so now he's
going for the e-file so let's see if I
follow my advice nope
so so I decided I calculated as like I
can get this pawn because if I play rook
to e1 now notice my rooks are not
connected anymore right so then he would
take King takes check maybe I could play
king of whether that looks really risky
and then if I go to their check I guess
I would have to play King to f1 but I
really don't want to do that anyway
he'll probably just play there anyway
and I might be in a world of hurt so so
you got to calculate through so when he
plays here it's true he's going to check
in with my up pawn but no worries
because I just want to pawn as well so
check and it created a scape Square for
my king king c3 we really want our king
active in the endgame we don't want them
sitting back there
and just you know with limited spaces to
move so rook takes so now I have a
choice right I can check him and take
this pawn right or I can protect this
pawn what do you do so so notice these
pawns pretty much garbage they're going
to be really tough to defend
long term just pawn pretty good
because if this bond Falls guess what
then my G pawn is going to fall and then
he's going to have F pawn and an H pawn
to pass pawns
so so you have to weigh the differences
and obviously you should know hey I got
to protect this pawn well well that's
where I sure look alright alright so
work the d7 check it doesn't matter
because he if he goes here obviously and
attacks my rook right I can just take
his pawn and protect my point so that's
why I give him a check but in this
census now I'm going to play each for
I'm not going to take the point by
controlling the check first and that was
good all right so rook attacks my knight
so I'm really excited when I found this
move so we have a lot of different
options right we could move the knight
and elaborate takes a three check we
could move our King up to b3 but that
may are even before but that might lead
to a perpetual checks
I'm not going up here we go back you can
just go back I try to defend again check
even if I do go up there check and and
then it's a draw by perpetual check okay
or
or what move can we play here to protect
the night Kevin do you got it how can we
protect the night other than with the
King which does play yes well yeah we
take the pawn which we do instantly and
then we get checked where we're not
we're not too upset about these checks I
mean these checks really aren't hurting
us too much so so that's okay so now
King attacks the rook attacks our night
and now we have some different options
right we could we could just have our
knight be a defender for the rest of the
game we can just throw them up there or
we can think hey if we play our knight
there we're going to get this big night
check here so that's what we're going to
do if when we were play our Neches to be
a defender here the game I just peed her
out to be a draw you know so so look for
your checks here and up be active in the
endgame don't be passive or else you'll
just be playing
hoping for a draw instead of you know
trying to win the game you know all
right
so c5 obviously I don't take I give him
that check here and now I'm crushing him
and the king is just wandering around
he's got no home the wanderer all right
and and now he's back he's back back to
this castle square all right so now
we're really excited those checks
really hurt him right I mean he forced
them all the way back to the back row
where he doesn't have many flight
squares now where my king you know he
got he got around around and around and
around and he's doing good because he's
he's got a lot a lot of different
choices when he gets checked like look
at this well obviously we play work that
you won threaten checkmate
when he plays check it's like who cares
King c3 so the only way to stop mate is
here and now what move do you think I
play to really hurt them here obviously
the move is rook e7 right rook e to e7
you got your rooks on the back row here
and luckily my knight isn't on b3 right
he's ready to join in and a be an
integral part of this checkmate here so
so if I was playing black here I would
thread my own checkmate right rook takes
pawn would be checkmate right all right
so but it doesn't matter because I'm
going to play rook check check check and
my knight gets in here with a check and
then we got this really fancy checkmate
yeah and obviously he didn't even
threaten the checkmate he played a some
bonehead move but uh but anyway so so he
played the fried liver his King never
got got safe and castled by the time he
got the g8 it was too late and just
totally crushed him okay so so a lot of
people will say hey you know we don't
even have to play the fried liver after
Knight to g5 okay here it is pure
garbage okay so here so e4 e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 and you'll say this
is fine just play Knight f6 and then
after Knight to g5 d5 pawn takes d5 and
now instead of capturing the
back right play Knight to a5 all right
so that allows the bishop to give a
Czech pawn up pawn takes pawn takes and
now white if you play right here
you play your Bishop just back to d3 so
if this Knight ever gets attacked you
can just swim into e4 okay so look at
this would you rather be white or black
in this position white you're up a piece
all your pawns are so so nice if you're
playing with the black pieces let's flip
the board here because if but if you're
playing if you're telling your students
to play Knight f6
I'll move three and then this would be a
very logical outcome of what could
happen so is this how your student wants
to play down a pawn in the opening your
knight looking silly on the edge of the
board you have not one but two isolated
pawns and you got really nothing going
for you okay where is the attack okay
you can attack my queen and then I can
just play Bishop to e2 you'll play
Knight to d5 and I don't know what what
you think you got going for you so
Knight to d5 attacks the night so you
know you can just play the knight back
and everything will be fine so so that's
why you never play Knight f6 I move
three hopefully that will just end the
discussion okay but I doubt it with
alright but if you want further proof
let's play let's play another one all
right
so so here's my game against the order
we'll do one more here where I just wipe
wipe off the kit and remember when you
play the fried liver here before you 593
in 95 a lot of people don't even know
how to even react
- this like like so bit so so now it's
just game game on here and he's down a
rook and things aren't looking well for
him yeah castle and ice guys King back
to e8 d4
now this guy he's only rated at 1100 I
grant you there's no 1700 but but people
you rather be on offense than defense
here and now we have a cool double
attack here everybody see it
yeah Queen efore attacks the rook
undefended rook and a feather night so
he decides all right I'll defend the
rook and attack your rook
all right so instead of playing Queen
takes Knight we stop early for the check
places King up and then we get good old
checkmate okay all right so you know
you'll see a lot of Scholastic games
that end in this very fashion where they
don't even know how to play d5 to defend
all right so now now here's a game I did
play against a 1300 Eric tank chenko you
might remember that from one of my very
first lectures I played Eric tank chenko
when he was even a better player I bet
he's like 1600 now but this is when here
was still about 1300 and moving up the
ranks now he tries to defend very well
against the fried liver attack so let's
see if he can hold on to win I doubt it
Knight takes King takes okay
now to check and so he's going for it
he's going to play King e6 and he's like
let's let's roll let's do this alright
so attack the pink piece knight to be
four
all right so he's threatening to play
Knight take C to check so I need to get
castled alright which I do he protects
his night with c6 so so this is a this
is a pretty common setup you'll see in
the fried liver attack if they play all
the optimal moves alright so so now we
want to just break open the center here
Knight takes c2 and this is where I mess
up alright I should be worried about
getting his nine billion point piece
here right so I should just take here
and then if he takes my rook this isn't
going to be very good for him Knight
takes pawn takes and now I have a really
cool move here it's attacking a pinned
piece well I have to make a pin first
obviously and then then I'll get them
yeah Bensimon got any ideas
rook d1 excellent and now he can just
give up the best move was actually take
the bishop here but if he plays anything
else h6 check me okay but you know I got
scared which happens I guess and so I'm
like alright worked the b1 okay rook to
be won and then he gets a he gets a
really cool trick and Knight takes okay
so so it's looking it's not looking very
good for me right now okay I've
sacrificed the night and and he just
managed to win two more pawns so
so you might say up a fried liver
doesn't matter but look at this I have
so much compensation his King is just
you know in the center close to me and
his knight can't move so so at this
point I'm not I'm not I'm not getting
down so I put the pawn in the pin so now
he gets out of that pin but he
voluntarily removed the defender of the
Queen when when people are playing on
defense it's really really tough to stay
strong and solid okay because people are
messing up whether they're playing
offense or defense it's just when you
mess up playing defense it's magnified
so much because you know you have to
play very precise so Bishop takes Bishop
f5 so that was pretty good
so so it's not looking good for the home
team here so I back it up and he gets my
rook all right so I need I need
something good to happen here fast all
right so I threatened I throw him to
take his uh his pawn there so he defends
it all right but but notice where he put
the Queen here basically in a four
Keable position with his king okay so if
I can get Knight to e4 check I'm going
to be looking pretty good here right
obviously I can't play it now because a
bishop will take so do I have any good
moves at all
yes so I can put my own Bishop to e4
that will that will get him from being
eaten and and then I can take with Chuck
alright so so this is a mistake you see
a lot in games this night has nothing to
do with this this bishops problem but
he's going to come in and interfere
anyway and try to get get in the middle
of it and bad things are going to happen
when he gets this so now I can just
capture capture and now I'm going to win
the bishop back here right with a simple
double attack so Queen check King up and
Queen takes the bishop here alright so
so now he's like Bishop the c5 attacking
f2 big mistake and Julian sees it
instantly
how about everybody else Kevin sees it
now it's on Danny Danny for the win
you want to scream it out yes yes
everybody got it so 94 not only does it
protect up to and attacks the Queen
attacks the bishop double attack it's
just it's just on now
so Bishop takes up to check I'm winning
now so I might as well just trade off
everything he gives me a big check and
just move that King to the center and
get him going
so obviously I go on to win in about 20
moves after this but uh but you see even
even if you mess up on offense okay
there's great chances he's going to mess
up on defense as well and when he messes
up on defense he's going to really
really pay for it okay so we got one
last game here and it has nothing to do
with the fried liver attack ha ha ha you
missed the whole lecture about the fried
liver attack all right so this is a game
I played against my producer Ben Simon
here I had the white pieces so it goes
on to one of the first comments as we
said even if you play like the
recommended way to play E 4 E 5 9 f3
knight c6 don't allow are after Bishop
c4 don't play Knight f6 obviously play
Bishop c5 Bishop e7 or that h6 move now
just because you play the h6 move
doesn't necessarily mean that these
bishops ax won't ever occur as we'll see
in this game ok we ready for this all
right
he plays these six but the same same
principle alright so there's the there's
the h6 move okay and now we've got
plenty of time to do whatever Knight f6
attacks the pawn get castled here b6 so
so Ben should probably be thinking about
getting this Bishop out and castling
alright so my king safe his king in the
center break it open
so now Bishop to g4
so after takes he takes and now our
Queens or you know in a line here and
obviously I can play the check because
if he takes free Queen
so King up check King takes and now now
I get a free pawn here Bishop here and
now now you can really taunt the rook
here okay
pawn it by attacking it rip back Knight
takes rook up pawn it again you gotta go
back a step and up you don't see that
every day huh yes Julian what is it
'if I've was played Bishop g8 couldn't
see it good see once I moved that point
I want to just keep them rolling keep
keep them give them gold because I'm
going to get a check and a queen and and
all the good stuff you're thinking too
small Julian thinking about getting a
queen and checkmate all right serious
yeah
all right so Bishop takes anyway this
rook is stuck right so I can do this as
anytime I still don't even want to so
what do you even think that you even
think that's still the best move
yeah Bishop defy Bishop d5 was played
forking everything Bishop takes c6 and
up and now now Julian let's see let's
see like like oh of course I'm going oh
I'll take the rook or I take the knight
right
do we have better than that think bigger
this time
yeah but you can win very very quickly
it's even better than rook takes f2
Wow that's what the computer wants me to
play because it's on it's unstoppable
now right yeah so so you might as well
play like the computer and check them
and King takes rook h8 Knight takes and
now you can't escape the checkmate right
and uh and then the game is over okay so
that's the fried liver for you and but
that wasn't the prize oh but but
essentially you get the drift so
hopefully you know teach the kids to
play the probably ver is white and to
stay away from three Knight f6 as black
okay
Oh